hello good evening good afternoon good
morning what is it there lunch time yeah
it's one o'clock just turning one
o'clock well even in here but yeah
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
um Movie Channel and we'll just do the
intro a bit and then we'll crack on with
the conversation
[Music]
my incense all screwed up because the
boys are here and they're all on their
Xboxes and things so we'll see how this
goes but
we've both seen the flash yes today
um I've literally just got back from the
cinema from watching it
first of all before I start complaining
I don't want to be one of those channels
of about everything but I feel
like recently I'm complaining about
everything well you know we got to get
people to increase the quality of things
you know yeah yeah but what did you what
did you think did you enjoy the movie
first
yes for the most part yes uh I I
actually would probably say it's my
third or fourth favorite DC film DC EU
DCU whatever the hell they call it not
DCU DCU is the new one I guess uh
so do you see
I'm a big fan of Shazam
the first one and then I'm also yeah the
first one I think is great and then uh
probably Wonder Woman and and yeah
maybe Snyder cut
yeah I think that's fair I like Batman
versus Superman I know I'm in the
minority on that one but other than
words
I've seen out
and because also there's no logic to
that bit all Batman
had to do a whole Superman had to do was
sort of go I'd you know there's a
million other ways I could have done
that instead of your mom's name's the
same as my mom's name
well I'm gonna put my neck on the line
for you then yeah of course stupid
change everything I've been doing for
the last
months there's just Logic on that one
but other than that I really enjoyed the
film I thought it was great
um it's just that bit
um I I'm I'm with you I don't even think
Aquaman is I think Jason Momoa was
brilliant but I don't actually think
Aquaman's a particularly good film no I
I like a lot of the stuff in it but
it's not it's it's fun it's not good
it's just fun the only good ones are the
Shazam and Wonder Woman were the two
that were actually good films and I wish
to them too as well was did as well but
it's just yeah Shazam two though they
ruined a bit because he he continued
um to act like this stupid kid and I'm
just like younger the kid's like 16 now
the kid doesn't act like a stupid kid
anymore
yeah he's about to be an adult like
yeah I don't know I don't know
um
Bob's just made fun there did this I I I
stopped watching The Flash on the CW a
while ago I will admit I am going to
make a point though that I actually
think when the CW did this exact same
storyline for the flash they did it much
better
um yes but my general feeling of the
movie why I dragged you in Harris
I didn't think it was bad movie I
enjoyed elements and by the way guys
there will be spoilers ahead we'll try
not to do it too much if you've not seen
it or you can't talk about the movie and
not accidentally say stuff can we so
there will be spoilers ahead
so
the CGI throughout the movie in the
first opening sequences it's it's
raining babies at one point and the
babies all look like they were made out
of plasticine
um
it's CGI that's so bad remember like the
second Matrix movie
and and at one point Neo looked like a
plasticine man and everyone's got to go
and that's terrible it's rubbish this is
never going to replace stuntmen and then
obviously it's got much better ever
since
no it's not arguably still better but
it's it's not far off
and that that was what 23 years ago 22
years ago something years ago yeah like
how is this this bad I know it's it's
because they tried to do too much
um but that whole scene was just bad the
only bit I've got amused me was at one
point you put a baby in a microwave and
I'm there going and then
if it goes ding it's plugged in so that
baby's cooked yeah the lady freaked out
which was funny yeah but I I just I just
thought it was
but the the CGI really wanted to
complain about
[Music]
AIDS we've had movies where there are an
actor will play two parts it's Freaky
Friday it's mine it's my twin it's
whatever it's
um when bloody nanu nanu
um when Mork met
um Robin Williams in real life and they
just they've been doing a few years it's
got better and better in this film
every time they were on screen together
one of them was CGI like deep fake deep
faked him and one was real
really very obvious once you noticed it
but at times which is which really
weirded me out he would be stood on
screen on his own and it was very
clearly a CGI version of him
because you you can just tell it's the
skin tone isn't quite right and
um and I really didn't understand that
um it's wine but a few times they said
they sat in the back of the plane
together and they sat next to each other
one is very clearly CGI and one is very
clearly real
why on Earth would they do that
uh I don't know honestly I I thought the
opposite I thought they did pretty well
with it uh but
all all things considered I was very I
had just partaken in the third M of M
cubed so uh
that might have been a nice filter on
top of things but I I'm not sure I I
thought it was all right generally for
that I thought the worst times for that
though was whenever one of them was
wearing like the bright red suit the
very CGI suit because then it felt like
their face was just kind of implanted
and kind of just it almost like popped
down to something it was
weird it wasn't as bad as Steven Seagal
on the front of the motorbike in one of
his movies but it it really wasn't that
far off in some ways which is bad the
first time we see Ben Affleck's Batman
as well he's on the boat and it looked
weird
the only I think Ben Affleck himself was
only in one scene like whenever that one
scene of him as Bruce Wayne was there
because the rest of CGI completely
yeah which is disappointing so again but
that's the thing it was unnecessary a
lot of The Siege again when the when
there's Ezra's and when the two flashes
are sat next to each other and once very
clearly CGI and one isn't I'm just
thinking that's not necessarily we've
been doing this type of thing for 20
years why not they do that yeah and if
you do it just do it like the
traditional style just do a little green
screen on and split it in half and then
make it look simple you don't need to go
the extra mile and spend the money where
you could use it to improve CGI
elsewhere I would be but it would look
better
yeah no definitely I don't know I just I
just can't get my head around why they
did it except for the fact that they
could
and that isn't good enough reason to but
because this was like the first
Justice League movie when they see gi'd
out in uh Henry cavill's mustache oh God
I'd not seen that they'd done that so
when I watched the movie all the way
through I'm still going
hell is wrong with Henry Cavill
something's wrong yeah why is it and
then at one point he smiles and you're
like oh geez he's like something is does
he think it's like the Joker almost yeah
yeah but they ruined the whole film for
me because then they're going
I'm not like Pokemon over this face all
the way through
um and I have to Google halfway through
the film I'm Googling things like that a
mustache just like and it just it just
complete I mean it's a terrible movie
anyway but it just that's what I felt
like in the flash although I threw him
going why why is that scene changing
why are they doing that she's going what
are you talking to shut up we're in the
cinema and I'm sorry but it doesn't make
sense why did it
um
nostalgia-wise my boys actually came out
when that's the worst film they've ever
seen really well I actually said I hated
that every second that movie is stupid
no way but um even the bits of the bits
I love though like the nostalgary bits
and they're too young remember Michael
Keaton as Batman
ah spoiler Michael Keaton's Batman for
most of this movie
um
yeah like you said every second of
Michael Keaton was just yeah
confectioners yeah it was absolutely
glorious
um a couple of the fight bits towards
the end weren't great but I mean other
than that but again because of the CGI
the one bit he's fighting a really big
Kryptonian
putting bombs and flipping over him and
I'm just I'm watching that going oh the
CGI for God's sake you you want to talk
about a bad CGI part with with the
Steven seagal-like mask was the first
time I don't remember the actress's name
which I feel bad about but but the other
like main zodman number two yeah the
first time you see her face is just
straight up just Steven Seagal on top of
it yeah because it's supposed to be like
through that glass thing isn't it and it
just doesn't work
um
the old Clutch Cargo animating series
see how bad things might just get no
that's fair enough but that's an old I
think this is a brand new movie that's
just yeah and it's supposed to be DC's
big I mean they were talking not long
ago about this film maybe being
nominated for an Oscar and um Tom Cruise
came out of like everything and was like
this is one of the best comic book
movies ever you got to go see it and
and it's not one of the main reasons I
went
how about we well let's ignore the CGI
we've randomly moaned about the CGI a
little bit what do you actually think of
the story is it is it is a compelling
story
yes but it's one that we have seen
before yeah and the done again and again
and again
it was well directed I think well done
but
it was it didn't bring anything new to
the table even Michael Keaton is Batman
the wisdom by The CW
oh yeah
um I will say though that Ezra
um is Ezra Miller yeah
um he is a good actor he might be nuts
and
um
and there's criminal issues but he's a
bloody good actor all the best actors
are mental well well and see I
I like the performance in this at all
honestly no no not like at all uh I I
just I just think the uh
the acting is very wooden in in this and
I think all of this Berry acting is very
wooden very like just buy the book it
doesn't like take risks or anything at
all it it's it's it's almost Peter
parker-esque in a way more so than Barry
Allen and uh
I'm not the biggest fan of the
performance in as Credence and or I
think that's the name and Fantastic
Beasts yeah
yeah but it's it's just it doesn't take
risk again you know for that type of
role he takes on roles that should be
very like risque and then yeah they're
they're more run-of-the-mill I think at
the end of the day we're like perks of
being a wild flower like way back in the
day that's that's that's decent this I I
just haven't like recent years have you
ever seen the Robin Williams Popeye live
action movie
it's like an acid trip without having to
take acids it's terrifying
um
yeah I just think that the story like
you said has been done before and I did
it better in the CW for me
um but honestly what did you think about
the humor because this this film tries
to be funny a few times
and I think it hit and missed
let's say it primarily hit but at the
same time it doesn't quintessentially
feel like Barry Allen it feels like
Peter Parker that I I just I don't feel
like it hit Barry Allen on the head
besides the mother stuff which is great
uh
no I would say that I don't remember him
ever being like a geeky when I was
supposed to be a case in the book was he
ever this awkward
and anything we've ever seen no Matt and
I were talking about this the other day
where we literally the first time we see
him is as like he he works in the
forensics forensics department and
a detective uh or a police station you
know he's a fully realized adult he's
not some kid and and it doesn't happen
to him when he's a kid either it's not
like a a a a late pubescent thing you
know he's a fully realized person and
has a career has a life
Etc and and we don't really get I don't
think we've ever really gotten that from
him he's always been like younger and
it's felt not like flash to me and and
that's that's I think that's a good
point I I say sorry I I do I've I've I
don't like to piss off Snyder fan
because I'm friends with plenty of them
but
I just I don't think many of his
characters in his version of the DC uh
EU I guess have been
the actual characters from the comics I
think that's my quintessential problem
with Man of Steel I uh that's why people
complain about Batman I think Batman
actually is closest because his
reasoning for killing people later on is
like
you could see that kind of person go to
that and that's the only one that kind
of makes sense logically to me I guess
it is a darker World generally there's a
lot of beneficial influence apparently
on the Batman couch we ended up seeing
in the end
yeah I mean I think that could be
apparently Ben Affleck was very very
early on he said I'm only doing it if
it's a Batman that makes sense to me I
would have loved the Batman movie with
him and Joe manganiello's Deathstroke
though that is like if if we missed out
on one DC property that was it right
there you think that would have been a
great movie
um
[Music]
he was gonna he was desperate to do it
but
and then it turned into batinson which
don't get me started on that one you
know what that's the fam I enjoyed I
just wish it was about 45 minutes
shorter oh I just wish it had a little
different plot
yeah the plot was trying to be real and
gritty and a detective and everything
else it was just too long but anyway it
didn't even feel like Batman he was
sidelined in his own movie and it was
Broody it was Kurt Cobain I I understand
like that was the inspiration for the
like character archetype but like it was
it felt like a copycat of a Kurt Cobain
performance over that's probably true
an actual Bruce Wayne
is this the end of the Schneider verse
now then
Aquaman
Aquaman's the very last one that's gonna
be it isn't it
does did you stay till the post-credits
scene couldn't be bothered walked out
what happened
yeah spoiler but it it's really not that
big of a deal it's Ezra and then he's
walking around his flash or not his
flash I guess he's just kind of
Barry Allen at the time and Aquaman uh
Arthur Curry as Jason Momoa was just
kind of drunk stumbling and then he kind
of like holds him in his arm and then he
falls in a puddle makes a couple jokes
he's like I'm gonna just sleep here and
just and that's that's it it's a funny
little scene it's probably one of the
best scenes in the entire movie honestly
like acting wise which is great uh
I will watch Aquaman 2 even if that
Bloody woman is still in it like I've
lost track of how many times stories
have said she's going to be cut out of
it or
um she's not gone out of it but I guess
I'm betting at least her screen time's
gonna be between 12 and 24 minutes if
not shorter killer earlier but um uh I I
will even put up with her because Jason
Rose and I say the first I I couldn't
stand the first there's a movie the
first Aquaman is awful but um but he is
just so great in it it just sort of
drags it into enjoyable so yeah I I like
Patrick Will's internet generally and
then I like the concepts of the
different kingdoms but
the execution was interesting and I
honestly I do like black Mana I like
Yaya Abdul Mateen uh I just didn't like
the way they did it it was too close to
the comic and it looked a bit silly that
was the worst thing that Marvel was
brilliant at was bringing stuff from the
comic but just drawn it in a little bit
you know sort of thing just just bring
it this side of silly and they just
checked things just to make it work a
bit better the early Marvel anyway yeah
yeah marvelous it's gone on they've I
think some people have complained just
things like um Ben kingsley's character
when they brought him in as the
Mandalorian but then I just love how
they switched that and made him like a
patsy and a bit now yeah I wish they'd
then stopped using because when Ben
kingsley's in Shai Lin
um I thought it was a little silly
um but I liked how they did that because
the Mandalorian character in the comics
was a bit it was very big very Grand and
I think on a movie that might not have
worked
but the way they did it was fantastic
um yeah it ended up working
yeah but um but there's lots of examples
of that but in DC they seem to that
seems to be a little bit scared that
people if fans of the comics are gonna
go oh you've that's not wasn't in the
comic and and so they made me realistic
and I'm like now you need to draw some
things but Marvel I think we've done
that in the last few films they've
the bad guy from Black Panther 2 with
the wings on his feet I've always said
that looks
but it's that's what's
yeah it's really it's really loyal to
the comics and I'm like oh yeah but old
Marvel would have done that and they'd
have done the character but they'd have
just changed something just
didn't have actual wings and Falcons now
like a military kind of unit in a way
yeah yeah
exactly just just change something
change it up a little bit mix it up a
little bit just to make it
a good like just exception just because
he is a mutant and that's gonna be our
first like he's our introduction to
mutants so that's kind of
a power base that he has to have I guess
in a way because it does he's very
Aquatic and stuff of course but he's
good in the sky you know oh yeah
Hermes flying around what do you like
black panthers like burns the wings and
I thought it was Griffin yeah but
um but now I I think it's going to be
very interesting to see what the next
phase of Marvel's like now Kevin feige
sort of retook the Rings
yeah
but yeah so generally speaking then
out of five what would you what would
you score
Flash The Flash yeah out of five
one being awful five being
Thor Ragnarok
uh
somewhere between three and a half and
four
that's I think that's a high score
I'm thinking it's a barely a two really
in bits it's a four and in bits it's a
one so I'll give it two and a half
see I I I there is a
pretty damn bad CGI at points but I
guess I I don't let that take away my
score in that sense just because if if
yeah just ignore it well just in the
sense like if any of the artists were
given another two weeks how much
different would it look you know it
might be a whole different scene uh if
they were given another month then we
might have like a beautiful scene and
then that might actually be Oscar worthy
I don't know where all that Oscar talk
was coming from but uh
that that I try not to like let affect
my thought process there but generally
the story was good it's a good story I
I'd stick with like a three and a half
just because it was it was very well
directed Annie muschetti I think did a
very good job
I I actually I'm saying like the bits
like I said with Michael Keaton stuff I
love this so much and bit to that film I
really really adore I loved seeing the
original Batman being again it was
almost my favorite Batmobile
Keaton is my favorite Batman on my
Facebook Facebook basically he's my
favorite Batman
um the first Batman bat movie was just
glorious it's just again it's never been
surpassed I love the end scene spoiler
when um you know the big joke and the
only joke in the movie that actually
made me laugh out loud
um was when he thinks it's going to be
Bruce Wayne yeah he thinks it's going to
be Ben Affleck British George Clooney
so I mean I I just thought that was that
bit of the movie genuinely made me laugh
out loud
um the other big jokey bit was when he
loses his powers and he's so so he
starts doing that slow run and he goes
oh my God I'm slow and it's like it's
just that just didn't make me laugh it
was awful
yeah what is there a big problem
no no you just talk about things that
made you laugh whenever uh I guess
spoiler alert again but the when when
main Berry loses his powers for the
first time and he tries to run around
the room and he freaks out for a minute
that made me laugh out loud like this I
just thought that looks silly oh the
ruined that he does and understand I
thought that was a bit silly but um but
that didn't amuse me so much but anyway
that's it all it's all taste whatever
yeah it's subjective but is there and
can we understand the big problem it
seems to be at the moment with Marvel DC
in particular that they're just not
spending enough time on the CGI
I mean yeah we can do a multitude of
videos off that Marvel just fired one of
the three Executives that's been there
since the very beginning like one of
Kevin fagi's two it's it's Nate Moore
and Victoria Alonso and Victoria
alonso's out like she she was one of the
primary like Hydra heads of of Marvel if
you know for a good metaphor over there
uh
she's gone which is
kind of weird I I don't know if Marvel
even knows what they're gonna do in that
matter I don't know who's replaced her I
don't know if they've even announced
that I'm pretty sure they probably have
done it but they just maybe haven't like
publicly announced it maybe they have
and I just haven't paid attention
uh
or maybe it's more of a committee role
now who knows but that that alone is
just shows how rocky that landscape is
in general because movies make
a Marvel have been the big one have they
been doing too many films too and Kevin
Foley seems to have come in and but and
and DC have done the same to be honest I
basically said look
we're doing too much
it's and it's become honestly over
quality we've got to slow down and
they've slowed down they think Star Wars
has been the same they've slowed down
all of their
um calendar
um
we can't cope we can't do it so let's if
we're not doing it right let's just slow
down and it is distracting the bad CGI
is distracting it shouldn't make a big
difference but it is distracting
um
so you've seen the Snyder cut right yeah
I would argue a lot of the CGI in this
movie is kind of similar to that movie
but in the way that movie handles it
it just feels not necessarily more
natural but it's more acceptable
does that make sense
I think the the Snyder could that they
fixed a lot of the problems from Justice
League
the story made more sense but more
importantly yeah a lot of the seeds yeah
and the main bad guy whose name I can't
remember
Steppenwolf or or or or dark side
and now Steppenwolf was the we don't see
dark side so much do we but the
Steppenwolf
they far improved the image the look of
him and everything else I mean he looked
scary in the Snyder version he didn't
and he looked a bit more like I don't
know I feel like he looked still more
like a CGI creature in the Snyder cup
just got what I'm saying I think he
looks better in like a scary aspect he
feels more like in Universe cool and and
proper cartoon I still see yes little
CGI villain rather than yeah because
they did try to put the actor's face
more on the first one Sierra and Heinz
or I believe uh
was better in almost everywhere
running on the short one tonight because
um we're coming back tomorrow again so
um we're having a video tomorrow guys by
the way so set your calendars I'll set
it up in a minute we're gonna have a
final debate on SGU
boring or awesome it might just be you
and me too
it's just me and you so we're gonna go
at it hard didn't we all right but I
know you loved SGU I did not so much so
that should be interesting but we're
putting this discussion to that we're
never we're never discussing it again
um that's what we're doing tomorrow so
um but the cameos in the flash right yes
big big part did they work for you
I have a very loaded answer for that so
I'm gonna counter with a a question for
you
what's going on
were they tasteful
um just
because the first two
right so we got Christopher Reeve and in
Africa what's her name as Supergirl uh I
don't I don't remember her name I've
forgotten all about that Supergirl
series until yeah oh my God I love that
um so but yeah
um the one the Nick Cage one he looked
bizarre but I quite like that they did
that yeah that was super CGI but I loved
it yeah I love the the early flash that
we actually got to see in the CW as well
because when one of the flashes came
over and but it was a guy that played
The Flash in the original series years
ago and he had the silly hat I quite
like that in the CWI actually it did
um yeah um so we just saw him we saw the
original Superman fat Superman
um
Georgie's right yep
um it was it was genuinely a bit of a
Superman in real life the guy was a
legend in real life but yeah
um again the um the movie that um Batman
from this did
about him was great go watch that
um was it Hollywood something
hollywoodland or something I forget that
one that's always called it anyway
um
the the but I I thought it was a bit
weird that they didn't have the flash
from the CW
oh well I I don't uh because if they
they included him that would be like a
justification in a lot of fans Minds to
just replace Ezra with Grant Gustin
which yeah you asked was a very popular
option at one point
which would still be a great option if
they were to continue doing all this
stuff which they're not so
switch it over find somebody new Ellen
slice for Supergirl you're right and
reef said no to do in a movie with her
which would have been awesome
um
but yeah love the inclusion yeah they I
actually thought that was quite well
done
apparently the real family did agree to
it so which is which is really nice
yeah
I I thought they were tasteful I I
thought they were like
just in the way they did them it was
like kind of like they were honoring
them in a way but it also felt weird I I
don't know exactly why it felt weird it
just kind of did
uh uh and that's where I'm like maybe it
wasn't super tasteful uh but it it did
feel like they were honoring them in a
way
I like to knit cage stuff a lot yeah but
I thought the Nick Cage one amused me I
have to admit I just wish they'd done it
a bit better that's the thing if they
would have done all the green screen
stuff with with Ezra and and just done
two pers two people on different screens
and and replace it the old-fashioned way
and saved a lot of money on the CGI they
could have made all of that look tinfold
better but have you seen the Kevin Smith
talking about the Nick Cage Superman
have you ever seen him talk about it
and there was the producer that was
gonna do it and he dragged Kevin Smith
in and he wrote this script and Kevin
Smith was really early in his career and
was really excited about it and they
said about Nick Cage doing it and you're
sort of like really
um and timbert was gonna direct but the
producer come in and said I really love
you Kevin but um I want massive spiders
that Kevin was like why because they're
great massive spiders none of bigger or
something and because she was just like
is this is he joking is he winding me up
um so I love that bit in this because in
that scene you wonder why there's this
giant spider and then the Superman and
it's Nick Cage and he kills the spider
and yeah and at the time I was like why
is that such a long everyone else has
just got a very quick little land look
oh what's happening but that was
actually quite a long little bit with
the Nick Cage which could have if they
would have done a little more CGI would
have been great
um
all of them have rendered a bit more
that that whole story is the reason why
isn't Like A Million Ways to Die in the
West is all the big spiders or it's not
maybe yeah
spiders yeah I can't remember the
producer's name but apparently he's just
obsessed because then Nick yeah Kevin
Smith was in that bit where he's talking
about it one of his live videos he's
then saying about and then he says that
he actually pretty much took the scene
that he'd wrote for the Superman bit and
and put it in Wild Wild West
was like that's my bed
um but yeah but he's just obsessed to
them for some reason but I love that
that they included that in the movie and
at the time I was like and then I
remembered the Kevin Smith bit and I was
like ah so I don't know if they're
taking the piss a little bit
or if that's just it's well known that
yeah there were going to be giant
spiders in that Superman movie probably
a little bit of both just for the
segment so lucky he didn't get made it
would have been awful but um
even I don't even gonna say that
yeah sometimes Executives do make wise
decisions when they uh
you know pull back from these problems
um but yeah it's I'm just yeah
have you seen across the spider-verse
yet
I I've not seen either of them I have to
I don't want a lot of cartoons I have to
admit
um I will watch it at some point I keep
meaning to it'll be jarring in a way but
it's also like
think of it like a comic book because
each one's drawn in their own very
specific way like according to their own
world and all that kind of thing so it's
like very specific and very Artful and
it's beautiful and kind of that way
focus on that instead of all the crazy
jarring aspects because it will be
jarring uh but they're amazing and I I
legitimately I I think I I'm I'm
surprised you thought it wasn't like you
gave it a two out of five because
I think it was a better Multiverse movie
than we've seen generally
yeah they've handled it better than some
of the other oh yeah recently I mean
it's not a story that we haven't seen
before of course but it's
Multiverse wise is is presented very
well
but after watching across the spider
verse
I won't ruin anything for you but they
have a lot of stuff and across this by
diverse because I mean you saw the
trailers all the different Spider-Man
everywhere so I mean there's almost
infinite kind of things similar things
kind of happen in kind of similar
Fashions and if this was released two
months ago I think it would have hit a
hell of a lot better because across the
spider-verse could just kind of knock
the win out of this with how well that
was made and done yeah
I'm giving it two out of ten
um because the flash is good I wouldn't
say it's great yeah
highlights between the cameos yeah I was
supposed to see the new Flash at the end
yeah but no comically if you have post
credit yeah
um
yeah maybe it's a chip short engine yeah
fast enough my internet's not fast
enough that's kid's fault
um
blame on the chips I've given it two out
of ten right if I was gonna compare two
out of five or two out of ten
two out of five sorry okay if I was
gonna compare it I'm comparing it to all
movies ever right yeah
um Predator Die Hard five five out of
five perfect movies then for me a bunch
of movies fours three I would still say
it's a good film I will watch it two is
um this should be better if I'm
comparing the flash though to movies
from the last 10 years it would probably
get
three and a half or four like you
because it's as good as some of the rest
of the tripe we've had over the last
decade or so yeah my rating comes from
BC I'm just I'm almost rating that in
like the in a DC mindset you know give
it a four out of DC movies yeah
it's it's not as good as Wonder Woman
the first one but if you look at like
Wonder Woman 1982 that's a one
how great of a director Patty Jenkins
can be that I that was just like phoning
it in it was yeah it was just it was bad
in many many ways
um but then but like I said but I like
Batman vs Superman but that would
probably get
for if I ignore
two minutes of the movie that's really
really bad
um this is awful though I remember
watching it goes
way to ruin a movie in 30 seconds
of skill
um just screw up an entire film in
literally 30 seconds yeah see that just
that was the cherry on top for me I
didn't like the logic of the entire
movie but it's still fun I think it's a
surface level good I think the other
biting is where the cyborg is coming
through the
Bruce Bruce that was pretty bad as well
um but the cyborg was terrible in all
those films should have just took it out
um
um but but yeah it's a DC film I'll give
it yeah three and a half
I think that's fair yeah generally as a
film I'd probably give it a three just
just because
for all of its its qualms you know I it
it was well directed and that's that's I
think it's best upside is just it was
well put together for all it wasn't
confusing it wasn't like it was it was
editing was good I liked how they didn't
explain certain things you know I like
excuse me you know I like game Supergirl
Takara it's a car right yeah car Israel
I really like Sasha Kelly
um but I I loved her outfit as well I
thought she looked great as Supergirl
um but so there's the bit where she's
obviously there's obviously like sort of
kryptonite or something or I don't know
if it's Kryptonite in that shell so it
looks like she's dying of cancer or
something she's all bone and that was
really well that CJ that was beautifully
done yeah and then they get her into the
Sun and she heals all right but she's
still weak but she heals they didn't
explain that
they didn't they didn't know they just
knew they said we don't need to explain
this we know everybody knows Superman is
healed by the sun we don't need to
explain it let's just do it and a lot
but a lot of other Marvel or DC or any
Superior films that keep feeling they
need to explain this over and over
and over again yeah you don't so um yeah
I thought that part was well done yeah
I'd like I like they've learned that
lesson even when uh flash is phasing and
he's walking through doors they kind of
explained it a bit later briefly but
they didn't go into that too much but if
you're not a fan flash you don't know
anything about that
yeah they kind of yeah like they did it
and then explained it which was nice it
was like okay well here's a brief
explanation for you let's just keep
doing it and they were like okay cool
little fun thing and then literally like
made the joke cool little fun thing and
and it was a good quit I I do like how
they made a little a couple of little
jokes about axeli so I like the one
where he faces through the floor but it
doesn't take the clothes with him and he
just appears naked and then downstairs
yeah again that that actually did make
me right back
I'm gonna have to move
[Music]
but yeah it's just such a it's such a
random film for me I think it's going to
be one of those films I was really
looking forward to it so my expectations
were up here
um and then parts of the movie met those
expectations right but when I watched
Multiverse of Madness Dr Strange two I
didn't like it and I didn't like it even
more when I watched it again
the love and thunder I hated and I hated
it even more when I watched it a second
time
um but actually I think I'm probably
going to enjoy the flash more when I
watch it a second time
I think the CGI won't bother you so much
because I'll I'll be waiting for it
um
I think I will appreciate I agree with
you I think it was well directed and
well edited and well put together
which is nice
um even the stuff we're talking about
with the CGI in the opening sequence it
made sense
yeah
um
I mean those babies flew though I mean
when they when the buildings collapse in
and they go through the window all these
babies like they're on Spring it's like
the microwave is just
oh he's done
um I'm gonna pull that a turkey
um but but yeah no it was just
I just I just think it was
badly done in those aspects but it's
well written it did feel like it made
sense it was logical it was tension in
places and I do think the acting
actually I I disagree with that one I
think Ezra Miller was actually really
good in this when he's saying good mom
goodbye to his mom at the end that was
good that was my girlfriend you know and
then
but
I thought he was cast strong in this to
begin with
yeah he wasn't good in yeah I I agree
with
um Mr kw1
um you can forgive about CGI if
everything else works yeah but when you
watch it the first time and you watch on
a big screen as well even though
actually I find sometimes I'm not sure
I'll tell you later bad CGI stands out
even worse which doesn't make sense on a
cinema screen sometimes they can hide a
bit of it
um yeah honestly maybe it's because it's
4K and Bubba
um on small scale sometimes it's like oh
I watch films sometimes going on I
watch it at the cinema I don't remember
CGI being this bad but um but still
might be almost but um
but yeah I think everything else has
done much better so yeah I think you can
forgive that it's like you can forgive
the only thing that I really watch a
movie I don't know how you feel about
this the other thing I really can't
forgive is bad editing
because it
ruins movies when it's badly edited
and um you know the worst example of it
was the the Transformers movies
even the first one
it's the editing because it's Michael
Bay yeah the bell end with his editing
and it's like it's a film should have a
rhythm and I've bitched about this
before on this channel I'm so sorry but
a film should have a rhythm right it's
you know yeah and then should build to a
crescendo and then and then maybe slow
down again then should have a rhythm to
it his films
but within within a scene action action
action oh we'll just stop a minute look
at the sunset
it's just
stop
doing that it's just like you're not
and I don't understand really the the
what is it good you didn't see that what
was it I thought it was it was Nikolai
Costa Waldo yeah
why was he in it uh I think he's done a
movie with Andy muschetti before
I'm sure
cool
um
sorry just I completely blanked I
started thinking about Game of Thrones
Michael Bay movies in the you know oh oh
yeah yeah because because I mean Michael
Bay has made some freaking amazing films
before the rock is one of my favorite
probably just general like action films
ever it's it's one of the most memorable
ones and it's not even like the most
action-packed but they use it so
precisely and perfectly when they when
they do that it makes sense and there's
still big boom bomb in there at the end
Michael Bay gets its explosions but like
they're they're sensical where in in
Transformers yes it makes sense for them
to have just like little tiny explosions
going on there there's little rubbing of
the metal against each other they're
sparking all the time they're giant
machines sure
but like it's not did you see the new
one yet rise of the Beast I feel like
this one apparently it's good yeah I
think he told me it's good as well I
really enjoyed it the the end kind of
goes into a CGI
a a crab fest that's that's my PG
version of what I usually say uh and but
it's it's like it's I don't want to say
it's acceptable because it's not but
it's it's it feels more acceptable I I I
movies need to get out of that CGI third
act just like throw in it's very gray
and there's a lot of robots there's a
lot of robots there's a lot of robots
cool uh and you know that could be
Marvel that could be DC that could be
Transformers that could be fast and
furious it could literally be anything
uh it needs to make sense I feel like
this movie made a lot of more sense
until probably that whole like kind of
climactic scene uh Transformers wise but
yeah flash did do better with that than
I think a lot of recent movies which was
interesting it seems you like ruining
movies
because it's just being used too damn
much by some filmmakers
and I I'd say yes and no yes for
particular filmmakers because they
heavily rely on it and I think that's
that works in some degrees and doesn't
in other degrees like uh I think Zack
Snyder is like the epitome of that
example where his DC animated stuff all
the things he animates there is or CGS
there tends to be well done
uh
but it's not like it's not like really
well done it's more it's more like
mediocre to good realistically but
within all It just fits within I guess
the world that he builds and and the the
he does color things in a specific way
it does kind of tend to wash out though
which is bad uh
and it's just like you can't see what's
bloody going on off the time but the the
my problem with the even the original
Transformers movie which is a good film
I enjoyed it yeah
um it was the because it was badly
edited and the Rhythm wasn't there
um but also like like the Transformers
voices it sounded like it was
disconnected from what you were seeing
and it's just it's just like oh God that
feels awkward never mind then I I play a
game with my kids when we watch
Transformers movies
how many times were they 100 most
definitely have died and we'd like it up
like 30 40 times together that would
have definitely died then
there's negative chance of survival on
these situations yeah because giant
hunks of metal catching you you're still
going to break every bone upon impact
like
it's like oh that poor guy's spine
a million pieces but it's just a fun
game to play I tell you what though
you're talking about
um
The Rock again though
I think about the rhythm of the movie
right because I did this not long ago
when I was watching The Rock and I was
just like because I've I've remembered
I've forgot it was Michael Bay and I was
like ah Transformers movie I hate his
editing and I started having a rant
about his editing but then I was because
it was in my mind I was watching the
film from that point of view and it
don't get me wrong it's a class movie
you know it's a star it's it's a it's a
great movie Sean Connery cage is amazing
in it
um but even in that film The Rhythm is
odd in places and it just switches
um Michael bien is brilliant in that
um but but you actually watch it from
the you can see his influence and it's
like trying to rewrite the wheel you
know there's different things in movies
that just work in The Sims are you
talking like when when Sean Connery kind
of gets his hair cut and then like like
the whole like Switcheroo I guess of the
vibe I guess it's actually pretty much
all the way through the movie you see
what he likes to do is he will
he likes to so he'll have scenes that
so you have scenes that are very quick
and fast movements and everything else
but then he'll cut in a scene halfway
through where it slows right down and
yeah for a while or something and then
and then then it cuts back like the one
example in transform is is there's a big
fight action scene going on and then
randomly just cuts and it's just Shia
LaBeouf with a flare
um or something and it's a big Sunset a
very pretty scene and he's just sort of
doing that really slowly and then it
cuts back into the action sort of thing
and then the Rhythm picks up again
um if you do that occasionally and in
the right places it can it emphasizes a
moment but if you do it constantly it
makes for a jarring
you you can't get into the rhythm of
what you're watching yeah
Michael Bay likes to do that a lot he
likes to instead of build into a
crescendo he likes to sort of Almost Do
like a stop start feel but it feels like
your stop started so but then it feels
like certain scenes just stick out
but when you notice it and start looking
for it it's in all of his films
um and he's and it's and it's and but
actually I shouldn't say it really
because once you actually start noticing
it it becomes really irritating
oh yeah I mean I really don't think
about it it's Michael Bay you you kind
of know what you're getting into when
you get into it
I still haven't seen 13 hours that's one
that I I need to watch uh I I think I
own the book yeah that's Michael Bay
am I thinking of the wrong film now I
think about 28 days uh uh 13 hours is
the uh John Krasinski war movie where
the Afghanistan Afghanistan I think uh
yeah
I never saw it but it's supposedly
really good so
yeah but it's well respected I just
don't get it myself it's okay just on
this but um
popular I don't like Chris Nolan either
don't like his style
but man I know
first Batman movie he basically built
his it's like a bit Tim Burton really
even big bass built his reputation off
the first Batman where he wasn't given
free reign Tim Burton was not given free
reign on the first Batman and then
because it did so amazingly well he was
given free reign and then Batman 2 got
Tim burtoned and that's why it's nothing
like is good but I love it and it's so
good
Batman he was then Chris Nolan was given
more rain and he Chris Noland it and
that's why they just got longer and
longer do not like The Dark Knight
I love the movie and it is a great film
it's not as good as the first one
oh I think Batman Begins is like the
worst of the three dark knight Dark
Knight Rises then Batman Begins I like
Batman Begins but you can feel the
formula from the studio it it it it just
I know I think that's a good thing on
that one because I think they rained him
in a little bit
I think the film's got more and more up
their own ass
oh I bet you don't like Interstellar too
I think that might be the only Sci-Fi
fan ever that thinks Interstellar is not
realistic
um
yeah the robot somebody's saying about
oh the robot makes so much sense no it
doesn't it would fall over
it couldn't it could not move that robot
that big box that just with the three
things it's it's a nonsense they got
they did get the black hole stuff right
we need the hacksmith industries to make
one of those robots now just uh wouldn't
be able to walk uh those guys could do
it have you ever seen them they're like
the real life freaking uh Stark
Industries but for you like Boston
Dynamics
they wouldn't they wouldn't do it it
wouldn't wouldn't work
um but the whole end sequence of
interstellar is an absolute nonsense
even though it's particularly accurate
by quantum mechanics
it's a nonsense
it finds a reason to make love kind of
the the reason but that's that's moving
that's just making it into a movie it's
science fiction yeah but they kept going
on about how accurate it was I didn't
know because it's so much science and
then there's just the fiction touched in
there and The Narrative of course I just
I just thought it was upside down ass I
just thought it went on a bit and I I
love them at the Martian and things like
that but I don't okay Martian's amazing
Nolan right
um Dunkirk beautiful movie I own it and
I haven't seen it
it's stunning I saw an IMAX stunning
a bit long but stunning so it doesn't
ruin all of his films but tenant or
tenants I love tennis I I it's not for
everybody though oh I love it did you
like Inception though
um
I did like Inception I have to admit I
did enjoy Inception even though like
everybody else ever I did come out of it
going what the was that what's
going on yeah
um because wait I'm not sure that made
sense and we spent about three hours
going through paper we're doing things
going I'm not sure this is this make any
sense at all it's the Charlie the
chalkboard meme yeah just trying to
figure it out mind maps and things I'm
not trying to figure it out but but I
did enjoy it I thought it was good film
did you ever see memento
because Memento is like one of his first
films and that's mine bendy too yeah
well I I find that a little boring I
have to admit but it's very clever
so if you found that boring my last
Chris Nolan question for you go then my
favorite Christopher Nolan movie
have you seen The Prestige
yes loved it yeah hell yeah okay
um
but well I always mix up The Prestige
Hugh Jackman Christian Bale and Michael
Kane yes a a great movie and
um I I really enjoyed it I thought it
was really clever
um I even but those two movies that came
out with magicians at the same time and
the other one
sorry Now You See Me
no no no no very similar sort of style
set back in the 50s with um
uh the guy that played Hulk that once
and was in Fight Club
Ed Norton Ed Norton was in it
um and they came out about the same time
uh I've got to find out what it's called
but um that was good as well Ed Norton
Magic movie
um but yeah I really like that uh oh The
Illusionist oh okay okay what do you
think The Illusionist was possibly
better I don't know I've seen The
Illusionist um
um but yeah Jessica BL was in that one
and that was cool
um Paul gianetti was in it and I love
him but um but yeah okay right cool and
thank you so much for for coming on just
for me to about the CGI in of
course
um but guys genuinely if you've not seen
it yet go watch it it is actually good
even if I don't even if I am complaining
a lot it is probably the best thing DC
have done for a while it's somewhere in
that two to four range somewhere it's
not a bad movie and I I honestly
honestly think I'm going to enjoy it
more the second time I think I'll enjoy
more uh in a couple of months when it's
on actually what what's streaming
service do these films end up on this
will be on max
yeah oh
um
where does HBO Max stuff go
um we the TV goes on to someone's called
Sky Atlantic in this country the movie
so maybe they'll go on actually I think
it's going to go Sky Cinema
Sky Cinema oh no okay which I get so
I'll be able to watch that if I get to
Sky Cinema I get Paramount plus free
there you go
so do it you can just go watch them
again watch the first episode of the new
Star Trek series didn't like it
which which is is the new one the new
world strange new worlds again or no
which I loved um the first season mostly
yeah I thought that was like the new
popular big one yeah yeah yeah yeah a
lot of truckies are going this is Star
Trek again I just didn't like the first
episode I'm hoping it's just a week
opening episode and it'll get better and
but there's a lot of it I didn't like
um but the thing is I think it's it's
possibly though because again that
expectations thing I was so looking
forward to it and then when I watched it
all the way through I was like
oh but maybe it just wasn't what I
was expecting so I think I'm gonna give
it a day or two I'm gonna watch it again
and then I'll probably do another video
going now I still hate it let's see what
happened
um so guys thank you so so much everyone
has jumped in the thing I know it was a
last minute live
um again tomorrow we're gonna be arguing
SGU so bring your arguing hats
um
it's just again it's just amazes me how
people
it's such a Marmite episode you don't
have mama in America there it's not you
don't understand that saying do you it's
like it's your Vegemite
or something like that okay I know what
Vegemite is I don't think we really have
it extract
yeah like toast right so in this country
it's like marmite's well known for being
either people either love it or they can
hate it yeah but it sounds delicious
yeah there's nothing in between it's
vile stuff
um
but yeah so it's a Marmite TV show
that's what the Seas that's what the
saying is you know so much Marmite it's
you either love I hate it nobody nobody
will ever just go it's all right it just
doesn't exist love I hate it
um so
um it astounds me whenever I do an
episode whenever I do anything talking
about SGU the comments and people either
think it's the best Stargate of a
and there's nobody ever just goes he's
okay
I I loved it sorry Mike Mike's already
saying it was crap in the comments we're
we're marmiteing it we're marmiting it
I'm I'm with I'm with Mike I'm I'm not
I'm not going to say it was crap it
wasn't crap it was still Stargate it was
still better you're the guy that's
saying it's all right I I will say it's
okay
um but for me
it's the same with Star Trek if you get
an okay Star Trek series that's not
good enough
this is this is Stargate SGU was okay
that's not good enough
so but we'll have the argument tomorrow
Orville Nation how you doing sir I don't
see you very often so it's nice to see
you
I love Mama and I love SGU oh Richard
Richard
we'll see you tomorrow then soon see all
you have to defend him
um
um but yeah
Marmite is hard to find most people wash
their feet
Bob I love you to death
I have no idea what you're talking about
I'm trying to make sense of it uh
whatever yeah whenever I get to see a
message from Bob I always I'm always
there's a part of my brain that goes
read it it'll be great and there's a
part of my brain that goes read it
you're very gonna be confused on screen
again going what the is so I love
hello Mama
um click the Bell notification
it's easy videos
um but we I only set this live up 15
minutes before we started Orville so
that's probably again why
um yeah Bob cracks me up as well he does
absolutely
um I just don't know whether I should
read them live because I just I'm always
going to take me down a rabbit hole and
I think sometimes it does it on purpose
as well because I think he's generally
trying to wind me up
because it comes out with some great
stuff but I love how his mind works you
know most people's minds go that way
some people just wanted to go that way
and I think Bob's are that way again
which is glorious so I love it
um but yeah really gets there yeah yeah
he gets there in the end like that but
um yeah so we'll see you at five o'clock
tomorrow
um between 9am in the in the US I think
so set your alarm
I'll be there I'm not going out actually
I am not going out tonight I'm going I'm
going out this evening so I I'll be back
by the night that's the same thing
but I I have to go present a play real
quick and then I'm then I go to uh I'm
going to the movies I'm gonna go see no
hard feelings at new Jennifer Lawrence
comedy at seven so I will be in after
that I'm gonna get some sleep I'm coming
in ready to just
fight for SGU give it my all fight fight
I'm gonna put up a poll tonight for get
people to rate it and we'll see
um like a stripper pull
yeah 5 p.m damn it Richards is out see
this is what I keep missing
ET late or drink tea with YouTube in the
background
exactly eat at the TV
yes all the other phone or iPad anyway
dude thank you so so much we will I will
see you tomorrow and yeah have a lovely
evening you do love your evening yeah
you're lately yeah 10 o'clock so I'm
gonna go and um go watch a movie I think
before we go but anyway good night good
night good night everybody
takes rabbits